a bunch of Star Wars film news came our
way as a result of Disney's d23 event
and I'm about to tell you all of it so
you don't have to scour the internet for
yourself sit tight first up a new Star
Wars Episode 7 poster designed by
veteran artist drew struzan was revealed
and it looks pretty sweet even if the
weird new cross hills of lightsaber
still looks funny the poster shows off
the characters finn rey kylo Ren and han
Solo thinners also seen wielding a
lightsaber which would seem to suggest
he is or will be turning into Jedi we
also saw him wearing a stormtrooper
outfit in the first trailer though so
who knows his knee also announced
details about upcoming standalone Star
Wars movie rogue one which is coming out
in December 2016 the star-studded cast
includes forest whitaker stiletto lee
jones fireplace alan shooter cannibals
Mads Mikkelsen and the dark knight rises
and mendelssohn the movie is set before
the events of a new hope and is being
described as a departure from the corp
films but will still feature familiar
elements finally in things worth knowing
it was announced that Star Wars Episode
nine will be directed by Colin Trevorrow
who recently directed direct world
production isn't expected to start for a
few years but trevorrose seems to have
accepted the role with a dose of
humility saying this is not a job boys
it's a seat at a campfire surrounded by
an extraordinary group of storytellers
filmmakers artists and craftspeople
we've been charged with telling you
stories for younger generations because
they deserve what we all had a mythology
to call their own let me know down in
the comments what you think about all
these Star Wars bits and pieces and for
all upcoming Star Wars e news and be
sure to keep it tuned the game spot